[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
it's seven o'clock i'm dermott monahan
this is a sky news question and answer
program about the cost of living crisis
featuring our panel of experts the
headlines a dark day for drivers the
price to fill up the average family car
hits yet another record high passing 100
pounds
it made me feel a bit sick just watching
it go up and up and up i couldn't
believe that it was that much
and there are calls for a fuel price
checker to keep prices lower as they do
in northern ireland to be introduced
across the uk
the prime minister pledges to make it
easier to get onto the property ladder
as he seeks to reassure people
struggling to make ends meet
we are on your siding cutting transport
costs are on your side in cutting the
cost of home ownership
and of course we are on your side in
cutting the tax bill as fast as you
responsibly can
well coming up our panel will be
answering your questions about petrol
prices energy bills and some of the
possible solutions
[Music]
a very good evening it's been described
as a truly dark day for drivers and the
rac is warning of darker days ahead it
now costs more than 100 pounds to fill
up an average family car with a 55-litre
tank so it adds to the pressure on
millions of people as there continues to
be a cost of living crisis meanwhile the
prime minister has attempted to rebrand
his leadership with a speech in
blackpool hinting at more tax cuts to
come and announcing more help for
first-time buyers to get on the property
ladder coming up we'll be doing our best
to answer the questions you've been
sending to us throughout the day
uh let's take you through some of the
numbers about the cost of petrol and
diesel well it's been rising sharply
this year unleaded petrol is 37 more
expensive than this week one year ago
diesel is also up now average is just
over 188 pence per liter the average
price of unleaded petrol is just over
182 pencil liter our business
correspondent paul kelso has more on the
rising cost of fuel
the car is crucial to the school run for
rosie and mum amy
but filling up is a nasty surprise one
we're going to have to all get used to
it made me feel a bit sick just watching
it go up and up and up i couldn't
believe that it was that much looking at
where we're spending every week you know
not going on foreign holidays you know
where's our money going i feel like
we've already been doing quite a good
job of tightening our belts
for unleaded petrol and diesel the 100
pound tank is now the norm motoring
groups want an immediate 10 p cut to the
taxes that make up 45 percent of pump
prices the prime minister suggested
retailers still haven't passed on a five
p cut made in march what i want to see
is
those cuts in taxation not just
swallowed up in one gulp without
touching the gullet
of the uh of the the fuel companies i
want to see i want to see those
those those cuts having an impact on the
pumps but with oil prices still high up
almost 57 this year that cut has long
since been negated by rising wholesale
prices
not least because sanctions against
russia a major supplier of diesel have
cut supply
retailers insist they're not
profiteering our members don't want to
sell at these prices but they can't sell
at a loss um i mean many of our members
know their customers personally they
come in on a regular basis and they know
the pressures that
you know this puts on household budgets
but unfortunately we buy on a wholesale
basis and we have to have to make money
out of it
petrol and diesel are at record levels
but it is not unusual as here to find
prices at the pump more than 10 p higher
than that and you don't have to be a
driver to be affected these prices are
nearly 40 percent higher than a year ago
and fuel is so fundamental to the
economy they're contributing nearly one
percent to general inflation everyone is
going to pay a price
charities like brent community transport
are feeling the squeeze they provide
transport for the elderly the infirm and
youth groups oh wow um it makes um the
one down the road it looks cheap
this is already 195
chairman moses is counting the cost of
filling each of his 22 vehicles 137
pounds
12 months ago and i'm really stretching
it 12 months it could even be less i was
filling up for nearly 80.
so
that's a huge
and there's no extra money coming in so
it has to come from our reserves how
long we can sustain that i really don't
know
we do know prices won't be going into
reverse anytime soon paul kelso sky news
well plenty then about the cost of
living to put to our panel let me
introduce them we've got polisoli
personal finance expert with us also
sarah ogilvy is policy director at the
child poverty action group they're with
me in the studio and uh joining us
remotely is frank van lover now an
economist with the new economics
foundation a very good evening to you
all well we've got so many questions
because this is such a
wide-ranging crisis so let's kick off
and say many many people have been
sending in questions throughout the day
to us here at sky news uh masood has our
first question which is
why are electricity gas and petrol going
up if we don't buy from russia well bala
you know that is the point that we get a
relatively small amount of our energy
from russia we know all about um the
problems caused by that so so why are
prices rising so steeply for energy yeah
even though um our uk supply is
privatized we have to think about the
fact
that
prices are going to compare in
comparison to what the market is doing
internationally so it's going to reflect
off of that irrespective of us not
getting most of our supply from russia
yeah i mean the uh macro economic view
frank uh the fact is that even if we
don't get much of our energy
particularly gas from russia it's about
supply and demand so um if other
countries that do get large amounts of
their gas from russia then access the
markets that we access the price goes up
yeah that's absolutely right so the
recent jump in fuel prices
like it highlights our vulnerability to
foreign oil
russia has curtailed its its production
and is shifting its supplies to asia and
away from
from europe which is driving a further
spike in increases but there is another
kind of macroeconomic force at play
which is basically that the the dollar
has increased
quite quite quite a lot since the
federal reserve bank has raised interest
rates which creates more demand and
makes the dollar more valuable and and
possibly there's an argument that since
brexit the value of the pound has gone
down and that and since you buy our oil
and petrol in in dollars effectively
that's made it more expensive okay
that's the exchange rate follow-on
question from our next viewer sam asks
i'll stick with you frank because it's
i'll say closely related why is the cost
of fuel on the rise is it because of
brexit or the war in ukraine or uh i'll
add in a multiplicity of factors
well yeah i mean
kind of coming back to what i was saying
the
there is an argument that brexit knocked
20 percent of the value of the pound
against the dollar oil prices are
effectively in dollars and hence the
petrol has increased that's raised the
cost of like by more than 25 percent the
but the flip side of this is actually
that it's more than the the value of the
dollar is actually increased maybe i i
by the way i'm neither a brexiteer or or
a remainer i'm quite neutral on that but
the fed has effectively
raised rates that that means that the
returns on american assets are basically
more profitable creating more demand for
the dollar increasing the value against
other currencies especially the crowd so
the the
actually the the price of brent is still
in dollar terms 20 below its 2008
all-time high the dollar is about
25 28.5 stronger than it was in 2008 so
brent has
peaked at about 74 pounds per barrel in
2008 today it's at 95 95 pounds so it's
still a third more expensive
and i you know i i'd actually probably
lean more towards the side that this has
more to do with the fact that the dollar
has increased quite a lot in value and
has a lot to do with some of the
macroeconomics well thank you for
explaining yeah yeah the effect of
exchange action we get that you are of
course you are a dispassionate observer
and can i just ask you bother on as
frank's describing there you know the
change particularly in uh sterling
versus the dollar that devaluation of
the currency of course puts up prices in
so many other areas as well particularly
those that are imported
absolutely it just means that we get
less for our money and it means our
money can't go as far as it was going
before so
we just have to think very wisely about
how we're currently spending a pound in
your pocket as uh a prime minister long
long ago uh famously coined the phrase
let's get another question and uh i want
to put this to you sarah steph asks
what's being done to ease the burden on
the younger generation you know we've
talked about so many areas where
particularly housing where the young are
missing out but there are many other
burdens as well i have to say derek the
answer to that is not a lot
and you know we heard from the
government a couple of weeks ago they
announced a package for helping
people to deal with the cost of living
crisis and one thing that was really
noticeable about that is that families
from a low income in particular got a
lump sum but they didn't get any extra
money for their children and we all know
that children cost money so you know
speaking about fuel costs if you're in a
family and you've got one kid or two kid
it's going to cost you more to heat the
house or to boil the water you're going
to have to buy more food so families in
particular are really suffering with
this cost of living crisis and
government just isn't putting money in
their pocket to help deal with that and
we also know that kids have really
suffered during covert we know that if
you come from a low-income family your
educational experience is much more
difficult than if you're
from a more well-off family so something
government could do is think about free
school meals for more children we
learned today that eight hundred
thousand children living in poverty
don't qualify for a free school meal
eight hundred thousand i did not know
that we know about the fuss that took
place last year about uh continuing free
school meals during parts of the
pandemic and how the government had to
more or less have its arm twisted to
continue with them but there are eight
hundred thousand who who miss out just
tell us a bit more about that so what's
happened is um over the past year or so
actually the number of children on free
school meals has gone up but there's a
real gap between the because the
eligibility criteria is so so
restrictive you can still be a family
living in poverty and you don't qualify
for
free school meals so what that means is
you've got as i say 800 000 kids we've
worked out today are going into school
the families are really really
struggling to pay the bills obviously
families will do anything to make sure
they're kids so sarah can i see these
are families who are receiving benefits
officially classed as in poverty but
they don't qualify how does that work
just tell us a bit about the criteria so
the mechanics are that if you are in a
family that is on universal credit but
is also earning which you know many many
families are
if you're earning any more than 7 000
pounds then you don't qualify for free
school meals and like you know that
sounds a bit technical but it just means
that as i say thousands and thousands of
children are going into school and
they're at risk of going hungry my
goodness me well thanks for illustrating
that thanks for highlighting that so
another question i'm going to put this
one then back to you frank we're back
into so many people are rightly
concerned about the cost of fuel and
peter wants to know i suppose many
people wonder this why is diesel more
expensive in the united kingdom than
petrol whereas in mainland europe it's
the other way around do we know this
because i mean diesel did used to be
cheaper in the uk than petrol but it
flipped at some point
i'm going to be totally honest with you
i am not a petrol
well all i know is as the former driver
of a diesel that it did used to be um
and we were encouraged to do so by um by
uh labor it was at the time that thought
at the time thought that diesel was less
polluting than petrol so there was an
encouragement to to use more diesel
vehicles and then of course over the
course of the last decade and a bit um
we've been discouraged because of some
of the particulates in diesel has now
been discovered didn't know that back in
the early 2000s or maybe we did and
maybe the government just didn't know
bollard do you know do you know why it's
more expensive in the uk than than
petrol whereas in mainland europe it's
the other way around i think it might
have something to do with the demand in
this country for it and potentially if
there's less demand for it the prices
have to be higher which is why in
general
um
some people say things like oh what if
we stop driving for example and well the
petrol prices go down and it's very
likely that's not going to happen either
so yeah well petrol does go down if
you'd if you don't drive at all but so
so many people of course have to have to
travel bola darren asked this i have a
choice
council tax or electricity and gas and
food it's not hard to choose the winner
well you know you've
you've got to eat um so yeah i know
which one you choose darren but then of
course you get into an awful lot of
trouble with the the energy companies
and your local authority so dilemma so
many millions of people are facing
absolutely i think what people need to
do now more than ever is speak to their
service providers it's so easy for you
to feel alone in this situation but we
aren't causing the situation and our
income isn't rising so as a result of
that we need to start having very honest
conversations with the people who
provide us with services and say this is
my current income and this is what i can
afford and see if there's anything that
can be done to work around your
situation yeah yeah so get advice on
that and sarah as i say that's a stark
choice faced by so many families at the
moment it really really is all year
families have been telling us that
they've got nothing left to cut back on
and you know the current cost of living
crisis is a real challenge but before
that families had the 20 pound cut to
universal credit they had to go through
covert which cost families loads and
loads of money and to be completely
honest there are some really long term
issues with the social security system
that means that there's been this break
between what families need and what
they're able to get in order to make
sure that their kids can live a healthy
happy life so things are really really
tough for families because they just
didn't have anywhere to go and this
crisis is really hitting them hard yeah
and what about help i mean you know
we've had a couple of packages from the
government we know about but people are
still getting in more and more difficult
circumstances i mean i won't pretend
that government hasn't done anything and
you know it did announce that it's going
to give families and who are using the
social security system 650 pounds you
know to see them through until next
spring but to be honest like you know as
we've heard costs are so high families
are already in so much debt and this
crisis has been going on all year in
addition to the other problems families
face so really that money is just going
to kind of maybe get them out of a
little bit of the debt that they're in
already but it's really not going to
help see families see themselves through
this summer holidays when you've got to
do activities for your kids when you've
got to feed them more and how it's going
to deal with seeing them through what
could potentially be like a quite long
cold winter that's you know it's really
really concerning for people and bola is
that one of the problems with you know
one-off handouts is that we don't know
how long this is going to go on but the
predictions are that it could be for
quite some time perhaps quite a few
years that one-off handouts well then
they get spent they cover they're an
immediate sticking plaster for the
problem isn't the more fundamental way
to do it to make structural changes to
to benefits to living wages and indeed
to taxes absolutely that's the best way
i know people want handouts and i get
why but as you said we're gonna have to
look at what happens in six months when
it gets cold and we see a rise in energy
prices we can't keep asking for handouts
every three to six months or every
quarter we have to look at long-term
solutions and the government have to
look at long-term solutions so that we
can all live
above the bread line and frank can i ask
you about that because if we get onto
the government and you know they're
hinting at it now making tax changes
cutting vat cutting income tax
that though impacts on the
on the debts on the money that the
government's borrowing and therefore the
servicing of that debt
yeah that's right i mean
we should definitely think about this in
different ways though because
um sorts of fiscal stimuluses that is
like an increase in
public expenditure can increase growth
and that also means higher tax revenues
it also means that the the so-called
debt to gdp ratio might actually fall
over time so there is a case where if
you use public expenditure in a
calculated way in ways that boost growth
that raise incomes and therefore raise
taxes that can actually lead to you know
a lower level of debt to gdp on the
other hand i mean there is a case that
if it's not used wisely that yes you'll
have a higher level of debt um and
without any interventions from the
central bank and absent any kind of
global macroeconomic forces you'll
probably see a you could see a higher
interest rate as well or definitely
higher interest and debt service and
costs is it a bit of a gamble though um
that tactic you described there of
cutting taxes to encourage growth um in
that there's going to be at least a lag
until that growth comes through and the
revenues from it and what do you do in
between time with interest rates rising
yeah
personally i i i if you were gonna
my
i i actually think tax reform should be
kind of done the other way around and we
should start thinking about actually how
we can reform the tax system so that
those with the broader shoulders
actually
shoulder most of the burden of the
of the cost of living crisis and we
should use public expenditure rather
than taxing we should be investing in
retrofitting homes investing in
renewable sources of energy
things that basically you know invest
now in the climate crisis otherwise the
costs in ten years time will be far far
more um furthermore those types of you
know you talked a bit
earlier about you know the effects of
consumption and sticking plasters tax
cuts have short-term effects on on the
economy investments creating assets over
the long-term infrastructure assets been
investing in education and health those
have long-term benefits for the economy
that can change the productive kind of
trajectory of the economy and and and
growth as well
so i i'm more dubious about tax cuts to
be honest if they should go anywhere it
should be for lower income households
um
but overall i'd say at least
in terms of reforming the taxes then we
should we should think about it the
other way around well plenty of great
suggestions from you all so far and
because of that you're going to stay
here listen you're going to stay here
anyway because we're going to take a
break you're watching this special
question and answer program about the
cost of living next we're going to be
asking what options the government is
looking at to combat these rising prices
and the squeeze on household incomes
stay with us
hello there coming up tonight at 9pm
i'll be speaking to dame emma thompson
and her co-star darryl mccormack about
their latest film and how emma felt
empowered to do a film all about sex
over the age of 60 plus she has some
strong words for the government about
the rwandan migrant scheme also on the
programme michael lewis author of the
premonition and the fifth risk which is
currently being made into a netflix
series by the obama production company
and catherine berbelsing on why she's
been named britain's strictest
headmistress that's all coming up at
nine o'clock on sky news don't miss it
it's a good one
[Music]
i'm stuart ramsey and i'm sky's chief
correspondent
well there's a real sense now that
people are beginning to expect that this
whole airlift is coming to an end and
they're really really desperate
we saw snatchbox going in grabbing
people and putting them into trucks
[Music]
you either live and recover
or you die
okay so that's like a wall that's the
war yes
we help you understand the world with us
over the past 24 hours the soldiers have
been attacked on a number of occasions
[Music]
it's really sending a clear message that
venezuela is eager for change
[Music]
to take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
they were convinced the united st
[Music]
the enormous explosion it's just come
down i think it was just landed in
between us
the information on this could bring down
the entire network not just in iraq and
syria but across the world
[Music]
[Applause]
sorry i could probably have withdrawn
it's so so hot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
the inspiration behind our product came
from
understanding how big of a problem
livestock meat and emissions were
welcome back you're watching a special
question and answer program about the
cost of living crisis and the prime
minister has been to blackpool today
attempting to rebrand his image after
four in ten of his own mps refused to
support him in a confidence vote you
remember on monday night in a
wide-ranging speech mr johnson warned
that prices will remain high for quite a
while to come and said there was no
quick fix for the ukraine conflict but
he said the government would do more to
help people on low incomes pledging to
make it easier for those whose wages are
topped up by the benefit system to
become homeowners
our deputy political editor sam coats
has more
for many this is the front line of the
cost of living crisis
the spiraling price of buying or renting
the roof over your head as bills of all
kind are increasing too
owning rather than renting a home can
make a massive difference for those on
the lowest incomes
andrew has benefited from a pilot scheme
that gave him the right to buy his
housing association home winning and
also security
the issue is is um some rules and
regulations change and as i've heard
here say of
they were talking about because my
children are growing up now i've got a
three-bedroomed house
that they might want to move me into a
bedroom flat
even though this is a home for the
children the kids come back here
hopefully one of their grandkids will as
well
and i just want to keep the property and
this is the guaranteed way of keeping
the property now because i bought it
they can't turn around and say we need
to transfer you to a flat
it's great
boris johnson in blackpool today and in
need of a political rebuild expanding
the right to buy pilot scheme the first
building block
and with it a promise of more precision
engineering to bring down costs
this is a speech designed to appeal to
his rebellious backbenchers as much as
the public it's time for the government
to stop spending and to start cutting
taxes and cutting regulation sometimes
the best way the government can help
is simply to get out of the way
to do less or to do it better or simply
and not at all
the pm covered everything from tax cuts
to olive tariffs to closing ticket
offices
but eventually got to his second big
housing plan i can announce a
comprehensive review of the mortgage
market reporting back this autumn it
will look at how we can give our nation
of aspiring homeowners better access to
low deposit mortgages and a promise to
refocus
uh that we will be able to get on with
the mission on which this government was
elected to unite and level up across
our country
so that no matter where you are born or
what your background we will give you
the chance to fulfill your potential
boris johnson's big argument here today
is that the government cannot spend its
way out of the cost of living crisis so
he wants to reform to cut costs today
housing soon child care and transport
but to deliver meaningful change he's
going to need unity from his cabinet and
the party and mps are going to be
looking to see whether the country is
with him
[Applause]
business owners suffer at work and at
home this restaurant opened months ago
the manager says rising prices means
fewer customers and less money for the
family at the end of the day
everything is going up
absolutely everything we cannot put the
prices high up
because we're going to end up closing
the shop so
we're trying to survive the best we can
behind the arcades blackpool is one of
the most deprived parts of the country
boris johnson promised long-term wins
for the lucky few but in places like
this not everyone can afford to wait
their turn
samcote sky news blackpool
well we've got plenty more questions
concerning some of the issues and
potential solutions that the prime
minister was raising there in blackpool
let's put them to our panel of experts
and we start with our next question it's
from rowley who said it's clear to see
that many households are facing
significant cost of living rises and
this is going to result in people
losing their houses and their jobs why
can't the government see this and act
now and rolly's describing i suppose the
the classic features of a recession
boller that is the issue if this gets
work many people could lose their jobs
lose their houses and that has a huge
economic effect
absolutely i
the idea of for example
raising
a wage or
something of the sort isn't going to
help because i do believe the cost of
living crisis it prices are still going
to increase unfortunately i don't feel
we have seen the worst of it and we're
not in a recession yet but many say that
a recession is coming and i do agree
with that so i think the government are
more likely to be reactive
to certain job losses and how and
housing issues as opposed to proactive
do you think that you think that's what
the government is doing now it's been
reactive what we've talked about the
absolutely couple of packages that they
came up with earlier in the year you
think they should get on the front foot
get ahead of it absolutely i think
what's hard it's it's hard to measure
exactly what's going to happen until it
happens so i do get the reason for them
um pacing themselves through everything
going on
sarah i mean this is this is the issue
rolly raises there that's
so many households facing significant
cost of living rises and then
if the economy really does go wrong and
remember the oecd are forecasting zero
growth next year for the united kingdom
if the jobs start going and
you know house prices start collapsing
we could be in real trouble families
could be in real trouble i think that's
really true and i think that is you're
right government has got to think long
term and it's got to think about the
structural way that our social security
system works so that if things do get
worse we're ready to help people out and
make sure that we can continue through
the crisis and come out the other end
that's why these one-off things don't
work because they don't give people
security and it means if things get
worse government is going to have to
keep reacting and reacting what it
should be doing is looking at the social
security system and other bits you know
of the the state and the support that
can be provided but look at it and work
out how do we get money to families how
do we make sure families are getting
enough money through that system so that
they can really live and so that they
can get through things and how do we
make sure that families are in a
position where
children can eat and they can and have
their homes heated the parents if they
can work that they can then be supported
to find jobs when they come available
but you know there's also loads of
reasons why people aren't even working
at the moment you know if you're a
parent and you've got young kids it's
often really hard to fit a full-time job
around childcare and we know that
childcare is hugely expensive so why
doesn't government think about looking
at child care or perhaps you're in a
family with a disabled child or you have
disabilities yourself then again you
might struggle to get a full-time job or
to work at all government really needs
to be looking after these people now and
into the future yeah ahead of it yeah
can i ask you though how how flexible
and reactive universal credit is because
you know we saw it from its genesis its
implementation that was problematic but
then did it come into its own during the
pandemic it seemed to get the the money
pretty quickly to to people something
like that could be used again so in
practical terms the universal credit
system did hold up better than some of
us were worried that it would do you
know the technology just about worked we
were able to get more people onto that
system so i suppose we can we can assume
that if lots of people do lose their
jobs in future that response will be
replicated
that's great but ultimately if there's
not enough money in the social security
fam system for families or individuals
to really live on then there's an extent
to which it doesn't matter if the
money's getting to you quickly and you
need to have enough in the first place
and but there's also again so there's
kind of issues like the amount of money
in social security system there's issues
like the benefit cap for the two child
limit that kind of limit the extent that
families can get money out of it but
then there's also kind of you might
think that they're technical issues but
there's a thing called the five-week
wait and that means if you want to claim
universal credit you can't get your
first payment until
five weeks after you've claimed now you
can get a loan to cover that period but
it means that you're going to this
really difficult period of your life
already in debt essentially and things
like that don't work in this kind of
situation okay we've got a question
coming up on the minimum wage but just
uh on this question from uh rolly frank
uh i mean to say this
big question here he's more or less as i
say describing a recession
how likely do you think
this is that uh we can see
people losing houses losing jobs that we
get to that situation
so i think there's two things
to consider here first of all
when recessions happen they can hack
they can take place in two formats
one is job losses but the second which
we saw post 2009 was rather than job
losses is reduction in wages or stagnant
wages
and
you know i think this is something
that's not actually discussed in that
currently but we were effectively
sleepwalking into this this cost of
living crisis
a decade of you know stagnant wages
meant that we would know when prices
start to go up we were in a very female
position alongside you know everything
sarah said by the way there's not in my
head because i completely agree with
that we had the weakest social security
system coming into this crisis
and in the 2008 global you know
financial crisis revealed the frailties
of our banking system the coded pandemic
revealed the weakness of our social
security system and we do need a
permanent
um solution to it and we need to make
sure that over the long term
effectively we can make sure that people
have um you know a minimum income
minimum income that that kind of
leaves you with a decent standard of
living
i'm interrupting there because that's
our next question ask that uh dan asks
and you know you mentioned falling wages
well you know there's one end of the
wage scale that the government can
control the the national living wage the
minimum wage dan asks what a substantial
raise to the minimum wage help with the
cost of living crisis is that uh part of
the policy prescription you would
recommend to the government
personally yes yeah as i was saying you
know households were already approaching
the current crisis in a financially
vulnerable position due to like 13 years
of a real
fall in average earnings um and across
two decades leading up to 2020 the
poorest 10 percent of families saw their
income grow by just three percent after
housing costs which is six times slower
than than the average
um so there is a case that we should be
increasing the minimum wage to 15 pounds
which i'm not against um
i i'd say that
that would definitely help the poorest
households um it would probably be one
of the strongest leveling measures with
33 of employees in london benefiting
compared to 51 percent of the employees
there there's a case that would also
substantially increase um taxation to to
over 30 billion and and just on that
note i just wanted to to make one point
because we heard johnson talking about
cutting taxes and that as a solution to
the cost of living
that's
in the current situation of the
recession cost of living that's kind of
like taking a bucket of water
and throwing it on somebody when they're
thirsty it is a very kind of
a non-targeted way to deal with the
issues and the primary problems facing
okay so you know
right a bucket of water and throwing it
on someone when they're thirsty so
bowler um this question from down a
substantial rise to the national living
wage i mean it clearly would help with
the cost of living crisis but how
substantial would it have to be yeah
personally i agree that's definitely
something that's needed and
something that will definitely help
hopefully in the short to midterm on the
basis that the cost of living crisis
doesn't continue to go up to a level
where even when it is raised it's
continued to be a problem so i would say
potentially
as frank said up to about 15 up to about
15 pounds per hour definitely for those
of you what about you know the small
business owners in particular they say
well you know we're under stress and
strain as well and
you know the national insurance rises
put um stresses and strains upon their
wage bill um this would add even more to
it
yeah i think that's more a question for
frank i'm a small business owner myself
so i question
what that what that means for me but um
unfortunately i will also be reactive
okay well listen i've got another
question here we're back to um back to
drivers and uh and the roads uh i don't
know who can actually answer this
probably only the government chams asks
why hasn't the government temporarily
abolished road tax
to help with the cost of living frank i
mean because that's all about you know
we there is no such thing as road tax we
know it's vehicle excise duty goes into
the the general fund of the treasury as
a cyclist i know this because i'm always
uh and as a driver i'm always ask why i
don't pay road tax uh you uh yeah
you know that as well i can see you
smiling um it goes into it goes into the
general fund but uh i mean it certainly
would help drivers
um
so
so yeah i think
first of all we should bear in mind that
fuel duty was was cut
by 5p
in
i think this is about vehicle excise
duty
yeah taxation
yeah generally speaking i
i i personally think that
there could be certain benefits to it
that they would be minimal and what we
should really be doing and thinking
about is cutting expenses for public
transport and increasing the capacity of
public transport and and the reason
being is that those those cuts in um
will not filter down to again the most
vulnerable and poorest households that
are most affected by the cost back to
you back to your bucket of water there
frank uh roy asks um well you know sorry
this is this is self-evident but this uh
well he asks is it cheaper to use public
transport rather than filling up your
car on average each month well you know
how long's a piece of string some some
public transport is awfully expensive
and it's pretty infrequent it depends
where you live yeah it's a real tough
one because you know we've heard how
expensive it is to fill up your car but
if you're a family and you've got with
two kids or three kids or four kids
buying train tickets getting them all on
the bus it's gonna be really expensive
but also it's really impractical as well
and like you might have to drop them off
at different places at different times
you know life is complicated and
difficult so yeah and you know if you're
a parent and you know one thing that is
often a factor actually and parents
deciding where they're going to take a
job it's because it's close to home or
close to the school so transport costs
are already a big factor and if you have
to limit the jobs you take to the area
really close to where you live or where
your kids going to school that often
means you can't get the best kind of job
that you could do so that's another way
that families incomes are being
restricted so yeah a fundamental look at
improving transport costs and
accessibility for families would be
really welcome yeah bottle i mean that
would make a a big difference wouldn't
it you know proper investment in public
transport infrastructure absolutely and
it very much depends on your location as
well so for example if you're living in
london the cost of public transport is
ridiculously expensive this is why a lot
of people do prefer to work from home so
that they can save money so it's a
question of what's going to be done to
target that it's a good point could see
more working from home but of course i
mean you know you mentioned about the
expense of public transport in london it
is relatively plentiful if you live in
other places particularly rural areas we
are talking and on this part of boris
johnson saying he's a fan of the buses
and i think sometime back another of his
announcements concerned a bus strategy
that um didn't seem to come to pass um
you know you you see one a day if that
and it costs you six pounds to to get
down the road if you want to come back
again you have to wait till tomorrow
absolutely i used to live outside of
london um during university and i saw
two buses an hour so i got a car
well no but that actually encapsulates
it let's get uh
a last question in in this section layla
asks if we all stop driving would this
bring down the cost of fuel at the pumps
yeah maybe they'd be offering you
incentives to buy it um you know an
economist can answer this because it's
about you know human behavior isn't it
um that if
the demand goes down and there's plenty
of supply then the prices drop
yeah definitely i think in the
introduction to the program there was
some some discussion about this
whether like actually you know retailers
are testing or speculating as to like
you know how much they can they can get
out of this these price rises and and i
definitely
would say that there's possibility that
the price would go down and people you
know all of a sudden people start to
stop buying yeah but of course bother as
you were saying there you know the
reality is
so so many people can't they'd like to
but they can't
agreed yeah absolutely there's there's
not much you can do given the situation
it's not necessarily in our hands all we
can do is respond to what's happening in
the economy
yeah and yet down down tools if if we
can but uh as i say in many cases that's
an impossibility you're watching a
special question and answer program
about the cost of living crisis coming
up next we're asking whether scrapping
vat on fuel could alleviate
some of the energy crisis
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back you're watching a question
and answer program about the cost of
living crisis in northern ireland we'd
be talking a lot about fuel well fuel is
currently less expensive than in the
rest of the united kingdom that's
partially down to a government website
which lets drivers know where the
cheapest petrol and diesel can be found
the consumer council updates its fuel
price index every week to tell consumers
the current average prices so they can
shop around our island correspondent
stephen murphy has been doing just that
northern ireland has the cheapest fuel
prices in the uk
not that motors here would know it is it
northern ireland does that come as a
surprise
way but it's extortionate
it feels like a reward is kind of gone
keeps going up and up and off prices are
usually three to four percent lower than
the rest of the uk where one simple tool
could help make a difference
one advantage motorists here do have is
this a consumer council fuel price
tracker it tells people exactly what the
average prices should be in their area
around northern ireland the aaa says
that this greater transparency helps
keep prices lower and it should be
rolled out everywhere in the uk
even the government-funded agency behind
the tracker doesn't think it's solely
responsible for lower prices but it does
say that it could help
the
aaa have been very nice and have said
that they think that our tool is
definitely helping keep prices down in
northern ireland we'd be a little bit
more modest but certainly having a tool
for consumers that enables them to see
what the highest lowest in average price
in their town is helps people to shop
around and get a good deal
when motorists know how much they should
be charged in their community it can
help them make a more informed choice
where to fill up a tool like that would
be helpful of course it would yeah but i
do shop around for fuel i mean i'll i'll
hold out and wait and go to the cheaper
one cost money to shop round we shop we
buy local and we stay local with the
diesel and paddle prices but to say it's
got crazy you know it's it businesses
are starting to struggle
fuel retailers say they dread each price
increase
you're looking oh how am i going to go
and put this price up on the totem pole
and you know people are going to say oh
this is you know crazy prices here but
at the end of the day you know we just
because of the cost we just can't sell
it at a loss we have to make some sort
of margin and profit off
could picking up the pump be less
painful with price transparency
the experience in northern ireland
suggests it could stephen murphy sky
news in county tyrone
well let's answer some more of your
questions about fuel and the
general cost of living crisis with our
panel of experts and this from rich
which uh relates to what stephen's been
reporting on in northern ireland rich
asks would it be viable for the
government to introduce a fuel cap rate
for petrol
and diesel uh frank what do you think
about that so you know with this the
there's the energy price cap would it
work for petrol and diesel
yeah definitely um there's
so there's an issue right now which
possibly you know petrol retailers are
not that there was a fuel duty cut
earlier they're not this is why the act
that you were talking that was explained
earlier might be working quite well is
because retailers are not necessarily
passing that on to their customers um so
there's what's called price gouging
possibly going on
um so a cat might help
at the same time
i know this might be a controversial
position but but it should be one that
we think about for the long term and
that is eventually over time we kind of
need petrol and oil prices to to
increase we want carbon taxes to take
place
um it's not something for the short term
but we need to think about again a
long-term solution
to this and i don't think a price cap
then is is that solution because
eventually we want people's behavior to
change and move more towards electric
vehicles you're right either the climate
crisis is there or it isn't we can't
ignore it just uh temporarily i suppose
uh baller um but a a fuel cap rate for
petrol in a diesel and and take on board
reflect on that stephen murphy reports
um even short of that a bit of naming
and shaming of those that charge the
highest prices and uh you know let's uh
publicize those that charge the cheapest
ones so then the consumers can make
their choices absolutely that would be
fantastic for everyone across the board
including myself to see exactly how that
works and who is profiting from what and
i think we could do with a cap but the
question is are we going to get it and
are the government going to give it to
us yeah the problem is though isn't it
if um you know you find it's 2p a litre
cheaper 50 miles away then you do 100
round trip to fill your tank up and it's
a little a little bit wasted
okay i've got another question from uh
mike saying well you know are other
countries facing the same significant
increase in fuel prices anyone know what
other countries are doing i know that in
some other countries in in france
certainly they've
managed to keep prices down a little bit
more frank
yeah it's actually the only country that
i think is it's got higher petrol prices
right now is france and outside of that
we're one of the highest and higher high
income countries
okay and why doesn't you we had a
question from cal saying why doesn't the
government get rid of the vat on few
fuel for a while sarah this is back to
what we've been asking about you know in
terms of overall tax cuts but vat on
fuel it's quite targeted um we were
prevented from doing that in the united
kingdom while members of the european
union it was mentioned by the vote leave
campaign it's one of the big brexit
bonuses but but it hasn't happened
that is something government could do
sure but i think there's there's lots of
other things that could do too that
either would be targeted at those most
in need or from the perspective of
children and families you know something
that responds to their needs so if you
know if it wants to do something for
everyone it could give families more
child benefit it could put every pupil
on a free school meals so that's
indirectly giving families the
equivalent of tax cuts but in a targeted
way that means that children are really
feeling the benefit of that in a way
that they're not going to do from lots
of these other measures that we're
hearing about i seem to be i'm confusing
our producers because i'm picking these
questions as they come but hey they're
all good ones um bola
terry r says you know we've done the
international european um comparisons
there terry r sis island has actually
slashed public transport fares by 20 we
were asking about that you know how
expensive public transport is uh cut by
20 until next year to help with the
crisis do we think a similar incentive
could work here i'll add in there terry
i know that um in germany they've
introduced a remarkable scheme for all
transport throughout the entirety of
germany which is a massive country at
nine euro for a month's travel
on its transport network um something
like that something comprehensive make a
big splash you think that would work
i think it absolutely would work i would
i would be happy at nine pounds for
example for that type of um service i
think what people have to put into
consideration is that in a good way that
would actually drive up the demand for
people to travel because they'll say
well prices have been cut back i am more
inclined to actually go out now because
i feel like i'm saving a bit of money so
i definitely think a little cutback will
definitely have a good increase in
demand
okay we've had plenty about transport
and fuel um we're talking
generally about the cost of living
crisis so let's expand it and um frank
this is to you and uh it brings in what
the prime minister was saying today
about he wants to get more and more
people uh onto the property ladder to be
able to buy their own homes but of
course some that then begs questions
about supply and demand again
and anonymous anonymous um
ask what actually makes house prices so
high
tell us about the economic forces that
seem to drive house prices up and up in
the united kingdom
wow okay so i mean that's a very
complicated question so i'll try to be
quick um
in in very short terms basically the
home since the 1980s has stopped being
home it's become a financial asset
um and it's no longer kind of used as
something for people to live in but it's
for for people to speculate and yes
they're we're commonly told that there's
definitely issues of not building enough
homes i'm very sympathetic to that
definitely in london you see
the wrong types of homes being built
lots of these expensive luxury types of
homes rather than more affordable types
of homes and that we definitely need but
at the same time there's two other
things that are happening and that's on
the demand side and that is that we have
a banking system that basically can lend
ad nauseam for property and so when you
have an infinite supply of money chasing
a finite supply of housing the housing
price is going to increase the second
side of the side effect of that of the
financial of the house being a financial
asset is that we effectively export our
housing stock we have a lot of foreign
investment and speculation in our
housing stock again it leads to that
that kind of infinite amount of money
chasing them okay i get it when you said
export our housing stock i had um
visions there of uh container ships with
uh loads of bricks and staircases i i
get it i i see what you're saying there
listen up from that from the macro
economic well let's end on this from
margot um who who asks or just states
really uh sarah take this on uh i don't
know if you did i had cookery lessons at
school now children don't simple recipe
leaflets would help do food banks offer
fresh food well that's a it's a bit of
both um but this idea that you know that
would help i
perhaps if you could prepare from raw
ingredients
might help a little bit so i suppose
there's two things i'd say in response
to that first of all is in direct
response to the question children do
have those kind of lessons at school but
if you're from a family from a low
income children are expected to bring
the ingredients in themselves and
families can't even afford that so
that's another way that children from a
low income are being cut out of the
education system so actually even
something that sounds like a simple
solution excludes children in education
but to look at the bigger picture
altogether you know i understand the
sentiment but really there isn't a food
crisis here in the country there's an
income crisis families don't have enough
money to get by at the moment and you
know fresh vegetables and you know
cooking is great but you need fuel for
it if you've got children you need more
food so ultimately it doesn't really get
to the heart of the issue and and i
think government's got to get a grip on
it okay uh bowler quick thought though
you know about
making your own meals from basic
ingredients would that help in terms of
personal finance is it actually cheaper
we know it's more time consuming but is
it actually cheaper
yes definitely of course you look at for
example takeaway services and you find
that if you just had the raw ingredients
it would be much cheaper for you to make
it at home so right now what people
should probably do is look at the
supermarket they go to is there a
cheaper supermarket they could go to and
maybe get the same product for a
a decent quality as well so that's
definitely something people need to look
at there's some great advice from you
all both for the macro and right down to
the personal advice as we expected
that's why we selected our panel bola
seoul thank you very much indeed
ogilvy very good to see you and frank
van leven excellent analysis thank you
all and uh you're watching sky news
tonight coming up on sky news tonight at
eight o'clock we turn to this situation
in ukraine where two british men have
been sentenced to death by
russian-backed courts the foreign
secretary has condemned it
[Music]
the plan is to take the political
temperature midweek so we'll be
discussing the biggest stories of the
week so far talking about what's still
to come having a look at prime
minister's questions of course and
getting reaction from politicians plus
our very own viewers and we'll have
analysis from my sky news colleagues the
take with sophie rich on sky news
the world seems to be becoming more and
more divided issues around politics
culture the pandemic are resulting in
vastly opposing viewpoints causing real
risks between us
i want to get in the middle of those
debates i want to better understand
where each stance comes from and whether
there's room for compromise
join me trevor phillips as we look to
find